تقدم للجمهوريين بمجلس النواب ومنافسه
شرسه بالشيوخ متى الملكه للفيسبوك تستغني
عن 11 الف موظف وسوري يبيعوا تذكره
اليانصيب الاغلى بتاريخ امريكا هذه
الاخبار وغيرها نقولها لكم من قناه
العربيه اهلا بكم
فيما يترقب ملايين الامريكيين من سيفوز
باغلبيه مقاعد الكونجرس بشقائيا وبشيوخ
ومناصب الحاكم في 36 ولايه افادت احصاءات
وسائل الاعلام المحليه بان الجمهوريين
حصلوا حتى الان على وسبعه مقاعد في مجلس
النواب مقابل 188 للديمقراطيين وفي مجلس
الشيوخ نال الديمقراطيون ثمانيه واربعين
مقعد المقابله 48 مقعدا ايضا للجمهوريين
حتى الان فيما يحتاجوا الجمهوريون الى 51
مقعدا لتامين الاغلبيه اما الحزب
الديمقراطيه الحاكم فيحتاج ل 50 مقعدا
بالنظر الى ان نائبه الرئيس التي تتراس
جلسات المجلس حسب القانون الصوت المرجح في
حالات التعادل
بعد ايام من قليله فقط على تسريح عدد كبير
من موظفي تويتر قررت شركه ماتا المالكه
للفيسبوك خفض عدد موظفيها بنحو 13 بالمئه
وابقيت على تجميد التوظيف حتى الربع الاول
من العام المقبل وكاله بلومبرج نقلت عندنا
مارك زوكربيرج الرئيس التنفيذي لميطا قوله
ان الشركه ستلغي اكثر من 11,000 وظيفه
مضيفا انه يعلم ان هذا صعب على الجميع
وانه اسف بشكل خاص للاشخاص المتاثرين على
حد قوله فيما ياتي هذا القرار بعد تراجع
الارباح الصافيه في الربع الثالث من العام
الحالي
في فاجعه ثانيه هزه الشارع الرياضيه
الاردنيه قتل لاعب صغير السن بعيار ناري
اثر خلاف في محافظه العقبه جنوبيه البلاد
بعد يوم واحد فقط على وفاه لاعب كره اليد
عادل عطاني بعد تعرضه الازمه القلبيه حاده
على ارضيه الملعب وصادر اوضحت للعربيه نات
ان لاعب نادي شباب العقبه يوسف ابو السند
لقي حذفه اثر تلقيه رصاصه قاتله خلال
مشاجره بين مجموعه من الاشخاص امام منزل
اللاعب فيما باشره الاجهزه الامنيه
والتحقيق في الحادثه والبحث عن الشخص الذي
اطلق النار
الى بريطانيا هذه المره حيث ضجت مواقع
التواصل بمقطع فيديو يظهر محاوله شخص رشق
الملك تشارلز وعقلته بالبيض اثناء جوله
لهما في مدينه يورك شمال البلاد الفيديو
ظهر القائها عده بيضات وسقوطها على الارض
دون ان تصيب الزوجين اللذين استمر في تحيه
الحشود فيما نقلت وكاله انباء بريطانيا ان
راشق البيض اصدر صيحات استهجان وهاتف هذه
البلاد بنيت على دماء العبيد بينما كانت
الشرطه تلقي القبض عليها
ولا في خبرنا الاخير ربح رجل مجهول الهويه
والجنسيه جائزه يانصيب باور بول في امريكا
والتي تعد اكبر جائزه ماليه بتاريخ
الولايات المتحده والبالغه نحو مليارين
و40 مليون دولار لكن اللافت في الامر وما
تحدثت عنه الكثير من وسائل الاعلام هو ان
من باع هذه التذكره الفائزه هو امريكي من
اصل سوري يملك متجرا في ولايه كاليفورنيا
فيما قدم مسؤول اليانصيب شيكا بقيمه مليون
دولار للرجل السوري لبيعه الاستماره
الرابعه